hey guys I hope you had a strong start
to this year
what is your finish goal let me know in
the comments below so today's workout is
going to be a really fun ten-minute
high-intensity body with cardio if you
hit the treadmill or even any cutting
machines through this workout I promise
you it's going to be a lot of fun and
you will be burning a lot of calories so
get your body warmed up and let's do
this workout together right guys are you
ready let's start you know jogging on
the spot we have about 30 seconds and I
want you to go crazy and really go all
out during this 10 minutes ok it's going
to be a high-intensity workout to really
push yourself
give me your energy and let's do our
best together all right keep jogging the
spot 20 more seconds each workout will
be for 45 seconds with 15 seconds rest
in between so the first workout will be
a white purpose with a little bit of
Jack ok this five more seconds
keep jumping just get your body ready
and let's go now so white Burpee jacks
down and is good jump in get white out
in and Jack nice keep going guys
remember the step light and jump in
slide Jack good
I love combination workouts it really
makes it more fun and so you will feel
like you're working on more muscles keep
going guys ten more seconds jump out in
out in
good luck work
and just rest it out okay second workout
will be a jump squad - hi nice ok so
give me two high knees and one jump
squat I'm just going to adjust my mic
slightly right go then shut it with a
pot toes pointed forward jump squat and
to high knees and down jump one two good
young one two jump one two down jump one
good really bring the knee up and jump
whoops pace your breathing
halfway there have this new jump want to
good tap those knees one two
okay fifteen more seconds I need to
catch my breath
remember to always pick the British it
really helped last one junk one just one
more jump one two good rest it out sweep
it back in mix we're guns will be slide
- double hop
okay so just jump to the bike double hop
jump to the slide double hop okay okay
breathe deeply and let's go double hop
jump double hop jump double hop jump
double hook to the side double hop so in
order to balance yourself you have to
work on your core jump double hop whoop
double hop good keep going white side
jump and hop double nice really feel one
leg being engaged at each time double
hop plus 10 seconds
jump Shabbo hop jump double hook to the
side double hop and rest it on your job
next workout will be a new and jump so
if you want to you can grab your Mac
kneel down okay and just pop up all
right now back down and hop let's go
kneel down pop down and hop
yes very nice so really use your body
momentum and push yourself up pop good
job guys keep going
whoa hop nice new top good let's go hop
engage those butt and leg muscles and
you will be very lost and lot this is
seriously more tiring than jogging on
the treadmill for a long period of time
keep going ten more seconds last few
long hop give me one more whoa
and hop and mess it up oh my god
Rockport Josh Martin Kaymer and Jack
price so again take your mat I just want
you to get into a must remember to type
and Jack crank why okay ready let's
finish strong plank jacks toy
flight nice Mountain claim bar solid and
hop well don't stop now you know with
five minutes into the workout hogs and
also Kaiba hop keep going
oh please
do not stop now do not drop now look
straight safe drop you're going to get a
one-minute break after this oh come on
guys
and take a one-minute right oh my god I
need to get my stuff hydrated and just
breathe
[Music]
all right guys five more seconds we're
going to do the entire workout but
another five minutes okay
the wife burping - Jax let's go out for
peace check-in out good high energy
paced breathing nice look straight up
and in
good job see your sweat dripping on the
floor that should be your motivation
whoo down and in
nice stay strong guys you're doing so
well out and a few more
and oh my god
rest it out dress it out next young
squad and Heinie's okay so jump as high
as you can and give me a nice high
please catch your breath I'm just good
to get rid of all the grass and let's go
down jump tiny flight down up one two
down up one boost up one two good jump
one two down up so really digged it and
go low nice
whoa do your legs muscles working you
can slow down if you're really feeling
tired let's try not to stop until the
very end okay jump one two whoa
down up thank you
rescue doc I know how you're feeling
because I'm feeling absolutely naked
sides to double hop all right guys
stay with me very little minutes left
right double hop right double hop good
double hop engage balance and hop hop
balance and hop good white that hop
white that hop very nice double hop keep
going
right then your knees slightly when you
land okay that will keep you more
balanced and also you will not be
straining
your joint slide double hop side oh nice
few more guide and rest it out next
kneel and jump this is a love-hate
relationship I don't like this workout
but I'll do it because I know it's dude
and it's like this so are you with me
let your new and jump up get down and up
here really spring and get your course
bring your body up swing up nice
swing up use your own momentum slightly
to bring yourself up okay swing up good
anymore guys stay strong I know your
legs and your bump are burning stay with
me
if I don't stop you're not stopping
alright keep going guys last one haha oh
my god
last workout I promise you multi-fiber
and Jack crying okay loss workout you
are done for the day right let's not
stop now let's go double muffin kinda
double jack plank double double
Oh engage those core engage those upper
body keep strong come on guys
you only have less than 30 seconds
you've come this far I want you to end
strong
come on keep planting keep jacking
you're with me breathe few more rest it
out well done
Oh just take a deep breath bring your
heart rate down and just stretch whoo
I'm sweaty I need to catch my breath
and this one is just shining right at me
and I'm ready to start my day if you're
through high on energy then go ahead and
challenge yourself to another two more
stats okay I want you to start or end
your workout session with this quick
10-minute high-intensity workouts to
really boost your energy boost your
metabolism and to also turn your body
into a fat burning machine be sure to do
this workout on a consistent basis
Electric video share and subscribe to my
youtube channel for more workouts videos
all the best guys
[Music]
you